está gravando ainda honra
eu saí liga e aí
agora não acho gostoso é o téo linda e
petrolina que hoje tem show aqui mais de
1.500 ingressos vendidos já avisava
galera de belém do pará dia 19 tem show
é e olha que ingressam mais cedo
sei que não é tudo aqui na descrição do
vídeo tem sua primeira encíclica e vamos
ao vídeo ter tudo bom e aí galera existe
uma palavra quando você está muito ruim
que meu deus gente agora eu entro no meu
facebook só tenho uma coisa urgente do
plano alguma coisa ou o teste eu abri
meu facebook eu vou mostrar pra você
[Música]
porque você quer descobre uma coisa
vocês me peça tudo com essa coisa é
legal é legal é interessante é
interessante o negócio é que a pessoa
pondera baixa ano consegue fazer um
consegue fazer dois ela tem que fazer e
15/9 portando atrasado ao evento você
não acho legal se não chegar eu acho eu
gosto é gente combine a voto demais é
demasia tudo demais não é um exemplo um
pedaço de asa um pedacinho razão é
gostoso por 15 pedaço de lasanha nua não
15 para se lavar gostou sim nutella um
pode o tela é gostoso agora 15 pode
nutella já dá uma caganeira e é como
estava o facebook está uma cadeira
mineira e do bairro que você vai adorar
só quer ser todo mundo versão brasileira
herbert richers não quer ser berti richa
alvamar que dublagem é uma coisa legal
se você parar pra pensar na história da
dublagem do dote é uma coisa você está
assistindo televisão
o filme começa dias impeçam brasileira
todo mundo ficava a gente
161 7 x 1 romã então não sabem brincar
avós e thierry seu próximo filme que vem
versão brasileira vamos agora vamos a
certeza herbert rocha droga droga
o melhor pra mim que eu acho legal de
dublagem quando o cara bota a voz de
criança para fazer uma pessoa adulta
quando botou o pessoal do avaí criança e
nem assim meio metro de altura achei a
criança é pequena e fala assim
olá quando chega o bombado gigantes em
tipo a regra chega assim à olá achar
mais engraçado assistir a um filme que
tinha ódio do blog assim aqueles fim dos
anos 80 até aqueles que nos anos 80 que
imitam na escola ayrton tentativa assim
é fazer bullying como nos outros anos
mas só que parece que todo mundo é bom
alegre todo mundo a sempre de bem com a
vida e quer fazer muito cara chega assim
à ai caras se acham que a gente praticar
um bom e velho bullying com os meninos
do 6º ano
é isso mesmo que eu estava pensando em
como acabar com ele o que mais eu
achando que há desculpas
acho engraçado quando a voz no caso com
a boca dos cantá e xarás o que acha de
pegarmos aqueles garotos do 6º ano em
que vão nessa porque na dublagem às
vezes a boca está fazendo uma coisa e o
som está fazendo outro tipo assim a
[Música]
degola e dodói que eu gostava mesmo era
aquele programa de depoimento que tem no
discovery channel que aquela do bairro
eles o melhor não tem pra onde não há
sequer a partida assim é o homem preso
nos escombros e pensei oh meu deus será
que vou conseguir só fala quando me dei
conta a estava embaixo dos escombros e
pensei oh meu deus será que vou falecer
foi então que avistei um caipira e achei
que ele ajuda o meu nome é epaminondas
eu avistei a moça mas não quis ajudar o
coxa passou ainda essas gangues e
dublagem não é agora que o facebook não
vamos brincar vão brincar é engraçado em
gaza vão fazer com moderação net você
gostou do vídeo você concorda que eu
falei que você faz e tac no youtube
cíclico gostei no youtube e no facebook
você faz e clique em curtir o que você
faz até os amigos
não estão fazendo muita brincadeira e
marketing nos comentários ela assistirá
no twitter da rtp que mais pessoas 112
vai ver ouvir e não se esquece de se
inscrever aqui no canal toda vez que
você se inscreva no meu canal todo o
vídeo que sair
você vai assistir a minhas redes sociais
toda a descrição do vídeo no twitter ou
facebook seguir meu twitter no instagram
tudo aí muito obrigado a se despedir até
aqui é nóis e falou no futuro a
qualidade da saúde no brasil